From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our story today begins in 1865 and ends this year, today. The moment in 1865 where we start is on March 4, the day Abraham Lincoln delivered his second inaugural address. I don't know if you've ever read this speech, but it's this incredible document, just four paragraphs long.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的故事始于1865年，终于今年，今天。我们切入1865年的那个时刻是3月4日，也就是亚伯拉罕·林肯发表第二任就职演说的那一天。我不知道你是否读过这篇演说，但它是一份不可思议的文件，只有四个段落长。
At the time that he delivered this, the Civil War was ending, over a half million Americans dead. And Lincoln uses the speech to ponder the question, why have we been visited with this war. Here are his words.
在他发表这段演说时，南北战争即将结束，超过五十万美国人死亡。林肯利用这篇演说来思考这样一个问题：为什么我们遭受了这场战争。以下是他的原话。
"Neither party expected for the war, the magnitude or the duration, which it already has attained. Each looked for an easier triumph and a result less fundamental and astounding. Both read the same Bible and pray to the same God. And each invokes his aid against the other. The Almighty has his own purposes."
“双方都没想到战争会有目前这样的规模和持续时间。双方都期待着更轻松的胜利，以及不那么根本和令人震惊的结果。双方读着同一本圣经，向同一个上帝祈祷。双方都祈求上帝帮助自己反对另一方。全能者有他自己的目的。”
And at this point in the speech, Lincoln posits this incredible image that slavery is a kind of original sin on this continent, an original sin for which all Americans must pay. He says, "Fondly do we hope, fervently do we pray that this mighty scourge of war may speedily pass away. Yet if God wills that it continue until all the wealth piled by the bondsman's 250 years of unrequited toil shall be sunk, and until every drop of blood drawn with a lash shall be paid with another drawn with a sword, as was said 3,000 years ago, so still it must be said, 'The judgments of the Lord are true and righteous altogether.' With malice toward none, with charity for all, with firmness in the right, as God gives us to see the right, let us strive on to finish the work we're in, to bind up the nation's wounds, to care for him who shall have borne the battle, and for his widow and his orphan, to do all which may achieve and cherish a just and a lasting peace among ourselves and with all nations."
在演说的这一点上，林肯提出了一个不可思议的形象，即奴隶制是这片大陆上的一种原罪，所有美国人都必须为这种原罪付出代价。他说：“我们热切地希望，虔诚地祈祷，这场巨大的战争灾难能够迅速过去。然而，如果上帝愿意让它继续下去，直到债券人250年未获回报的劳动所积累的全部财富被消耗殆尽，直到每一滴被鞭子抽出的血，都要用剑抽出的血来偿还，就像3000年前所说的那样，现在仍然必须说：‘主的审判是真实而公义的。’对任何人都不怀恶意，对所有人都要宽容，坚持正义，正如上帝让我们看到正义一样，让我们努力完成我们正在进行的工作，包扎国家的伤口，照顾那些承受战争的人，照顾他的遗孀和孤儿，尽一切可能在我们之间以及与各国之间实现并珍惜持久的和平。”
Well, today on our program on this Fourth of July weekend, we raise this question. How're we doing absolving ourselves of our original sin? To answer that, let's fast forward to the 1990s.
那么，今天在我们国庆周末的节目中，我们提出这样一个问题：我们在消除原罪方面做得如何？为了回答这个问题，让我们快进到20世纪90年代。
You hear how I'm talking now? I don't talk like this when I'm around my friends who don't speak like this. When I go to a school like this, everyone is speaking like this. So I have to do my best to blend in, which I kind of do pretty good. I pretty much have everybody thrown off about me. They pretty much know nothing of where I come from.
你听出我现在说话的方式了吗？我和那些不这样说话的朋友在一起时，我不会这样说话。当我进入这样的学校时，每个人都这样说话。所以我必须尽我所能融入其中，我做得还不错。我基本上把每个人都弄糊涂了。他们几乎不知道我来自哪里。
This is Eliyahu Miller. When I recorded this, he was a sophomore at a Chicago high school named for Abraham Lincoln, Lincoln Park, in a rich neighborhood in Chicago's mostly white North Side. Eliyahu rode the bus for nearly an hour a day to get there from his home in a neighborhood on Chicago's mostly black, mostly segregated South Side. One measure of how far we have to go in healing the wounds of the past is the distance Eliyahu had to go between home and school.
这是埃利亚胡·米勒。当我录下这段话时，他是芝加哥一所高中的二年级学生，这所学校以亚伯拉罕·林肯的名字命名，位于芝加哥以白人为主的北区一个富裕社区。埃利亚胡每天要乘近一小时的公共汽车，从他位于芝加哥以黑人为主、且大体上种族隔离的南区的家中赶到那里。衡量我们在治愈过去创伤方面还有多长路要走的一个标准，就是埃利亚胡在往返家与学校之间所必须跨越的距离。
It is hard on a person to come to Lincoln Park. And your friends, they have $50 in change and then some. And they have these expensive things. And then you go home, and you're slapped in the face by reality. That's why I spend so much time at school. I hate to go home.
来到林肯公园对一个人来说很困难。你的朋友们口袋里有50美元的零花钱，甚至更多。他们有这些昂贵的东西。然后你回家，却被现实狠狠地打了一耳光。这就是为什么我在学校待那么久。我讨厌回家。
As for me, my whole life, I haven't been prejudiced. And up until this year, I've been totally free of all prejudice. But it's just gotten to the point where I can't hold it back anymore.
至于我，我一生都没有偏见。直到今年，我一直都没有任何偏见。但现在情况到了我再也无法抑制的地步。
This is Chris, a senior at Lincoln Park the year I interviewed him. America's biggest experiment in integration, integrated schools, left Chris intolerant mostly because of tense, little interactions he used to have all the time with black students. Some of them were his fault, he said. Some theirs.
这是克里斯，我采访他时是林肯公园高中的四年级学生。美国最大的融合学校实验，让克里斯变得不再宽容，这主要是因为他过去经常与黑人学生发生紧张的小摩擦。他说，其中有些是他的错，有些是他们的错。
There was an incident recently where I was trying to go out of a door that someone was standing halfway in, halfway out. Said, "Excuse me." So I went through.
最近发生了一件事，我想穿过一扇门，而有人站在门中间，一半在里面，一半在外面。我说：“抱歉，借过。”然后我就穿过去了。
Guy started saying, "All these doors and you had to go through this one." I said, "That's right. Yeah." So he starts saying, "You better keep walking, white boy. I'm going to beat your ass," and all this.
那家伙开始说：“有这么多门，你非得走这一扇吗？”我说：“没错。是的。”于是他开始说：“你最好继续走，白人小子。我要揍死你，”等等之类的。
I just stopped and said, "Excuse me?" And he said, "You heard me. I'm gonna--" and just wanted to get into it. And I just basically blew it off.
我只是停下来问：“你说什么？”他说：“你听到了。我要……”他就想打架。我基本上没理会他。
And then it continued. I went to class. I came out. And a whole bunch of people surrounded me, "This is the one. This is the one." And I'm just standing there like, "What?"
然后事情还在继续。我去了教室。我出来时，一大群人围住了我，“就是他。就是他。”我就站在那里想，“什么？”
And then one of them said, "Yeah, he called this student a nigger" and all this. And I said, "Hold it. I didn't say any of that."
然后其中一个人说：“没错，他叫这个学生黑鬼”之类的。我说：“等等。我根本没说过这些。”
It seems at one point the whites were at a higher level than the blacks as far as social standards are concerned. Now rather than it being equal, I think-- in a black's mind, I'm speaking-- in a black's mind, the blacks are much higher than the whites. And they're band together. And they're not going to accept any whites in that band.
看来在社会标准方面，白人曾经处于比黑人更高的水平。现在，与其说是平等，我认为——我是在替黑人着想——在黑人的心里，黑人比白人高得多。他们团结在一起。他们不会接受任何白人加入那个团体。
There's still just a lot of resentment from that '50s, '60s slavery, whatever, times. But if you look at history, how long things have been, as far as slavery, how long did that go on for, how long did it take before it ended? So how long is it going to take before blacks and whites can get along as well as blacks and blacks and whites and whites do?
从50年代、60年代的奴隶制以及不管什么时期以来，仍然存在很多怨恨。但如果你看看历史，看看事情已经持续了多久，就奴隶制而言，那持续了多久，在它结束之前花了多久？那么，黑人和白人要花多久才能像黑人与黑人、白人与白人那样相处呢？
Well, today on our program, four attempts at answering that question. Act One, Another Politician Has God And The confederate Flag. Act Two, Nelson Mandela and Abraham Lincoln. Act Three, Good Blacks and Bad Blacks. A story by New Yorker writer Malcolm Gladwell. Act Four, Racial Cheerleaders. A story about somebody whose attitude about race did change. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，有四种尝试来回答这个问题。第一幕：另一位拥有上帝和邦联旗的政治家。第二幕：纳尔逊·曼德拉和亚伯拉罕·林肯。第三幕：好黑人和坏黑人。由《纽约客》撰稿人马尔科姆·格拉德威尔讲述的故事。第四幕：种族拉拉队长。一个关于某人的种族态度发生了改变的故事。请继续关注。
Act One, a modern politician, his god, and the Confederate flag. Well, not long ago, a governor of a southern state made his own attempt at binding up the nation's wounds and achieving a lasting peace among ourselves. And frankly, it has not gone too well for him.
第一幕：一位现代政治家、他的上帝和邦联旗。不久前，一位南方州的州长试图缝合国家的伤口，在我们之间实现持久的和平。坦率地说，这对他来说不太顺利。
The governor was David Beasley of South Carolina. His state is a good place to examine how well the wounds of the Civil War are healing. It is the only state in the Union that flies the Confederate flag over its state House
这位州长是南卡罗来纳州的大卫·比斯利。他的州是考察南北战争创伤愈合程度的好地方。它是联邦中唯一一个在州议会大厦上空悬挂邦联旗的州。
Our contributing editor, Jack Hitt, is from South Carolina. And this past Thanksgiving, he watched the television address where Governor David Beasley proposed that they remove the flag from the statehouse flag pole.
我们的特约编辑杰克·希特来自南卡罗来纳州。去年感恩节，他观看了戴维·比斯利州长提议将那面旗帜从议会大厦旗杆上撤下的电视讲话。
The governor of the state, he's a Christian coalition candidate, one of the few who actually won high office in the elections of '94. So Beasley took control of the governor's mansion. And not long after that, a number of different things happened. Some churches were burned. There were some drive-by shootings both of blacks and of whites by people of the other race. And tensions got very, very high.
这位州长是基督教联盟的候选人，是94年选举中少数真正赢得高职位的候选人之一。所以比斯利控制了州长官邸。在那之后不久，发生了一些不同的事情。一些教堂被烧毁了。还发生了一些针对黑人和白人的种族间驾车枪击事件。紧张局势变得非常、非常高。
And Beasley is a good, decent man actually. One of the things that I've tried to explain to people when I've written about him is that it's a mistake to think that everybody in the Christian coalition is like Ralph Reed, i.e., a slick, media-wise, focus-group-opinionated, Washington-lobbyist insider.
事实上，比斯利是个善良、正派的人。在撰写关于他的文章时，我试图向人们解释的一点是，认为基督教联盟的每个人都像拉尔夫·里德那样，即一个油滑的、精通媒体、受焦点小组意见左右、华盛顿说客圈内人，是一个错误。
At one point, I remember you described Ralph Reed as being "sincerity challenged."
记得有一次你形容拉尔夫·里德“缺乏真诚”。
Yeah, right. And the irony of that is that most of the people that I know in the Christian coalition in South Carolina are, in fact, deeply sentimental about the efforts to bring equality to the races in the state and the whole civil rights effort. And in a funny way, this is going to be Beasley's downfall. Because what he did after these various shootings and other acts of violence was decide that the Christian thing to do was to take down the Confederate flag from the statehouse.
是的，没错。讽刺的是，我在南卡罗来纳州基督教联盟认识的大多数人，实际上对于在该州实现种族平等的努力以及整个民权运动都充满了情感。有趣的是，这恰恰会成为比斯利的垮台原因。因为在这些枪击事件和其他暴力行为之后，他决定基督教徒该做的事就是将邦联旗从议会大厦上撤下。
In other words, it actually was a change of heart, and there was not much political advantage in it for him? He stood not to gain politically from this move?
换句话说，这实际上是一次内心的改变，对他来说并没有太多的政治利益？他在这个举动中没有获得政治上的好处？
I have asked everyone I know in South Carolina, "What would be the political advantage of a Republican bringing down the Confederate flag?" And there is none. It might be one of the few cases in American politics right now when the politician said, "I went, and I prayed. And I've decided to take down this flag," that that is, in fact, what happened.
我问过南卡罗来纳州我认识的每一个人，“共和党人撤下邦联旗有什么政治优势吗？”答案是根本没有。这可能是目前美国政治中极少数政客说“我去祈祷了，我决定撤下这面旗帜”而这实际上就是发生的事情的例子之一。
Well, good for him.
好吧，这对他来说是好事。
So he wins no points in his own party. It'll be so costly that I feel certain he will be thrown out of office at the next election.
所以他在自己的政党里没有赢得任何分数。这将是非常昂贵的，我确信他会在下次选举中被赶下台。
Because of his stand on the flag?
是因为他在旗帜问题上的立场吗？
Because of this. Because of this, yeah.
是因为这个。因为这个，是的。
OK, so he comes on television and--
好的，所以他出现在电视上，然后——
He comes on television, and what was really-- I'm sitting there with my entire family. We were all watching this. And everybody in the state is clearly watching this. It's on all the channels. It's been talked about in the papers for days.
他出现在电视上，而且非常……我当时正和全家人坐在一起。我们都在看。州里的每个人显然都在看。所有的频道都在播。报纸上已经讨论了几天。
The governor's going to address the state. And the two rebuttal arguments put forward are by other Republicans. No Democrats spoke. No black person spoke. And the other two people who spoke, Glenn McConnell, a local state assemblyman from Charleston, and Charles Condon, the Attorney General, clearly have their eyes on the Governor's chair, especially Condon.
州长将向州民发表讲话。而提出的两个反驳论点来自其他共和党人。没有民主党人发言。没有黑人发言。而其他两位发言者，查尔斯顿当地的州议员格伦·麦康奈尔和总检察长查尔斯·康登，显然都盯着州长的职位，尤其是康登。
But what was amazing about Beasley's argument for taking it down and Condon's argument for keeping it up is that they both manage to stake out rather nuanced positions about the meaning of symbols in contemporary American culture. It was strange, as I sat there listening to the Governor talking about how meaning works. And as you know, there is an entire academic discipline devoted to how we interpret signs.
但令人惊奇的是，比斯利关于撤下旗帜的论点和康登关于保留旗帜的论点，他们两人都设法在当代美国文化中象征的意义上阐明了相当微妙的立场。当我坐在那里听州长谈论意义是如何运作时，这很奇怪。如你所知，有一个完整的学术学科专门研究我们如何解释符号。
Right. And this is the field called semiotics, a sort of very arcane, in a certain way, academic discipline, which has swept across academia in this country in the last 15 years. Frankly, not the kind of thing which appears in our American political debate very often.
没错。这就是所谓的符号学，在某种程度上是一种非常深奥的学术学科，在过去15年里席卷了美国的学术界。坦率地说，这并不是那种经常出现在我们美国政治辩论中的东西。
Not very often.
确实不经常。
In fact, you've written about this. I'm going to read from your writing. You say, "The speeches themselves were novel for their departure from the debate's old terms, flag is evil, flag is not evil. Rather, these speakers put forward nuanced arguments of semiotics, the science of symbols. And I don't mean they argued that the flag debate signified other issues beyond race. No, I meant that they were actually arguing semiotic theory."
事实上，你写过关于这个的内容。我要读一下你写的内容。你说：“这些演讲本身因背离了辩论的旧术语——‘旗帜是邪恶的’、‘旗帜不是邪恶的’——而显得新颖。相反，这些演讲者提出了符号学（即符号科学）的微妙论点。我的意思不是说他们争论旗帜标志着种族以外的其他问题。不，我的意思是他们实际上是在争论符号学理论。”
Yeah, let me just read you the-- this is Beasley talking, as he's explaining why we should take the flag down. He says, this is a quote, "You see the Confederate flag flying above the statehouse flies in a vacuum. Its meaning and purpose are not defined by law. Because of this, any group can give the flag any meaning it chooses. The Klan can misuse it as a racist tool, as it has. And others can misuse it solely as a symbol for racism, as they have."
是的，让我读给你听——这是比斯利在解释为什么要撤下旗帜时的讲话。他说，这是一句引语：“你看，悬挂在议会大厦之上的邦联旗在真空中飞扬。它的意义和目的没有法律定义。正因为如此，任何团体都可以给这面旗帜赋予它选择的任何含义。三K党可以滥用它作为种族主义工具，就像它曾经做过的那样。其他人也可以滥用它，仅仅作为种族主义的象征，就像他们已经做过的那样。”
And so he's basically articulating what is the central tenet of modern semiotic theory which is that you have this object, a flag, and any meaning can attach to it.
所以他基本上阐明了现代符号学理论的核心原则，即你拥有这样一个物体，一面旗帜，任何意义都可以附加在它上面。
Right. But then what was amazing is that the other people who were refuting him or rebutting him basically delved into the same kind of theory. For example, here is Glenn McConnell, a state Senator from Charleston talking about the flag.
没错。但随后令人惊奇的是，其他反驳他的人基本上也深入到了同样的理论中。例如，这是查尔斯顿的州参议员格伦·麦康奈尔谈论这面旗帜的内容。
He says, quote, "We are told this flag lacks definition and must be moved to define it. But the flag was defined years ago on a monument on the statehouse grounds, which says that in the hopelessness of the hospitals, the despair of defeat, and the short, sharp agony of struggle, these South Carolinians who answered the call of their state did so in the consolation of the belief that, here at home, they would not be forgotten."
他说，引用如下：“我们被告知这面旗帜缺乏定义，必须被移动以进行定义。但这面旗帜多年前就在议会大厦广场的一座纪念碑上被定义了，上面写着：‘在医院的绝望中，在失败的挫折中，在斗争短暂而剧烈的痛苦中，这些响应国家号召的南卡罗来纳人，怀着在家乡不会被遗忘的慰藉行事。’”
In other words, the flag has a meaning, and that meaning is stable.
换句话说，这面旗帜有一个意义，而且那个意义是稳定的。
That meaning is stable.
那个意义是稳定的。
In other words, if the flag means honor, it's always going to mean honor. Other people can try to attach what they want, and it'll still mean that.
换句话说，如果旗帜意味着荣誉，它将永远意味着荣誉。其他人可以尝试附加他们想要的东西，它仍然意味着那个。
And it doesn't do any good. It's a very strong point of view in the South and especially in South Carolina. This is why I'm saying that I think Beasley has sort of wounded himself fatally.
这没有任何用处。这是南方，特别是南卡罗来纳州一个非常有力的观点。这就是为什么我说我认为比斯利已经某种程度上致命地伤害了自己。
One of the things that I find most interesting about this in light of Lincoln's second inaugural is that the second inaugural is essentially a Christian document. It's both a political document, and it's a document arguing about faith. What are we to make of this as people who believe in God? The fact that the war happened and so many people have died. And it's interesting that Beasley would also, basically, come to this conclusion that we need to heal, the same conclusion that Lincoln comes to, as an act of faith.
鉴于林肯的第二次就职演说，我发现关于这件事最有趣的一点是，第二次就职演说是本质上基督教的文件。它既是一份政治文件，也是一份关于信仰的辩论文件。作为信仰上帝的人，我们该如何理解这一点？战争发生以及这么多人死亡的事实。而且有趣的是，比斯利也基本上得出了我们需要治愈的结论，这与林肯作为信仰行为得出的结论相同。
Right. Well, I understand his thinking. And he came very close to pulling it off. If you appeal to the Christian sentimentality in South Carolina for good race relations, you have enormous support. Because most of these people, they don't want this antagonism, and they don't want the kind of bad feelings between the races publicly. Privately-- and this goes right to the heart of, I think, not just the South's, but America's ambiguity on race-- which is that the same heart that can get very weepy and sentimental about rebuilding black churches can also get infuriated with black leaders talking about how we need more affirmative action.
没错。好吧，我理解他的想法。他差一点就成功了。如果你利用南卡罗来纳州关于良好种族关系的基督教情怀，你会得到巨大的支持。因为这些人中的大多数，他们不想要这种对抗，也不想要那种公开的种族间的不良感情。私下里——我认为这直击不仅是南方的，也是美国在种族问题上的模棱两可的核心——同一个可以对重建黑人教堂感到非常流泪和感伤的心，也可以对谈论我们需要更多平权行动的黑人领袖感到愤怒。
So Jack, I know that you have your own modest proposal on how opponents of the Confederate flag flying over the statehouse might be able to actually get the flag off the statehouse.
所以杰克，我知道你有一个谦虚的建议，关于反对在议会大厦上空悬挂邦联旗的人可能如何能够真正将旗帜从议会大厦上撤下来。
Well, yes, I do.
是的，确实。
And it, in fact, is based on semiotic theory.
而且，它实际上是基于符号学理论。
It is based on semiotic theory. I think the remedy would be for blacks in South Carolina to start flying the Confederate flag.
它确实基于符号学理论。我认为补救措施应该是让南卡罗来纳州的黑人开始悬挂邦联旗。
Adopt the Stars and Bars as their symbol.
采用“星条旗”作为他们的象征。
Adopt the Stars and Bars as the symbol of the New South. In our culture, especially, where signs and symbols can turn over so quickly, it's very easy to do what none of these guys on television were proposing, which is add even more meaning to that symbol. That's the only way you can actually alter a symbol's meaning. Even if you took the flag down, its power would remain. Its power, whether it was in a windshield or on somebody's front lawn, would still remain.
采用“星条旗”作为新南方的象征。在我们的文化中，特别是在符号和象征可以如此迅速更替的地方，去做电视上这些家伙都没有提议的事情非常容易，那就是给那个符号增加更多的意义。这是你真正能够改变一个符号意义的唯一方法。即使你撤下了旗帜，它的力量依然存在。它的力量，无论是在挡风玻璃上还是在某人的前院里，依然会存在。
I would love to see baseball caps with Malcolm X, X is sort of rejiggered into the Stars and Bars configuration, or the Confederate flag washed with a little African liberation colors. And only blacks in South Carolina could possibly pull this off.
我非常想看到棒球帽上有马尔科姆·X的标志，X以某种方式重新组合进星条旗的结构中，或者邦联旗被染上一点非洲解放的颜色。只有南卡罗来纳州的黑人才能做到这一点。
Right. "It's our South too."
没错。“这也是我们的南方。”
And my further prediction is is that if this did happen, if blacks did start wearing it on their T-shirts, and on their cars, and on their coats, and flying it in their front lawns or whatever, that the first group to rush to the state capital and insist that the Stars and Bars be lowered would be the Daughters of the Confederate Veterans, so enraged they would be that they symbol's true meaning was being altered.
我的进一步预测是，如果真的发生了这种情况，如果黑人们真的开始在T恤上、车上、外套上佩戴它，并在前院悬挂它等等，那么第一个冲向州首府并坚持要求降下星条旗的团体，将是“邦联退伍军人女儿”组织，她们会因为象征的真正含义被篡改而感到愤怒。
But in a certain way, looked at at the distance of a century and a quarter after Lincoln, how are we to view this entire debate?
但以某种方式来看，在林肯之后一个世纪又四分之一个世纪的距离回望，我们该如何看待整个辩论？
I don't know. On the one hand, it seemed to me so many of the truly meaningful acts of integration have been accomplished. In a way, it's the kind of fight you would have after you've done all the hard work. We're really arguing, almost literally, about window dressing.
我不知道。一方面，在我看来，许多真正有意义的融合行为已经实现了。在某种程度上，这是你在完成所有艰苦工作后会进行的争论。我们几乎是在字面上争论关于表面文章的问题。
But I have to say, there's another way to look at this debate. And that is that the fact that this is what's being debated about race relations and the place of blacks and whites together in society, if this is what's being debated, that means that there are all these other things which we have not solved, which are never discussed with the same fervor and political heat. You're saying the governor of South Carolina is going to lose his governorship over this symbolic question of whether to fly a flag. He is not losing his governorship over whether black children are educated as well as white children.
但我必须说，看待这场辩论还有另一种方式。那就是，事实是这就是关于种族关系以及黑人和白人共同生活在社会中的地位所争论的焦点，如果这就是争论的内容，这意味着还有所有那些我们尚未解决的其他事情，从未以同样的狂热和政治热度进行讨论。你是说南卡罗来纳州州长将因为这个是否悬挂旗帜的象征性问题而失去州长职位。他并没有因为黑人孩子是否像白人孩子一样接受良好的教育而失去州长职位。
That's true. That's absolutely true.
那是真的。这绝对是真的。
Jack Hitt's a magazine writer and a contributing editor here at This American Life. After he published his idea that blacks adopt the Stars and Bars, he discovered that two black entrepreneurs in South Carolina have a company called NuSouth that's trying to do exactly that. These two guys, Sherman Evans and Angel Quintero, have a full line of clothing that feature the Confederate flag rendered in the colors of African liberation, red, black, and green. They have a store on Main Street in downtown Charleston. They hope to expand to all 13 original colonies.
杰克·希特是一位杂志撰稿人，也是《美国生活》的特约编辑。在他发表了黑人采用星条旗的想法后，他发现南卡罗来纳州的两位黑人企业家拥有一家名为“NuSouth”的公司，正试图做到这一点。这两个人，谢尔曼·埃文斯和安吉尔·金特罗，拥有全系列的服装，特色是以非洲解放色（红、黑、绿）呈现的邦联旗。他们在查尔斯顿市中心的缅街有一家店。他们希望扩张到最初的13个殖民地。
Realistically, we all know that the Confederate flag is the negative enemy. And the creation of a New South flag is kind of an act that don't move. We figured it's like the oppressor's worst insult, where we take that, and we wear it with pride. It's kind of like a strategy whereby you go right into the feared thing, and you claim it.
现实地讲，我们都知道邦联旗是负面的敌人。而创造一面新南方旗帜是一种不奏效的行为。我们想，这就像压迫者最恶毒的侮辱，我们接受它，并引以为傲。这就像是一种策略，你直接进入那个令人恐惧的事物，并声称它是你的。
Do they have a website? Well, of course. www.nusouth-- spelled N-U-S-O-U-T-H-- dot. com.
他们有网站吗？好吧，当然。www.nusouth——拼写是N-U-S-O-U-T-H——点com。
Act Two, Nelson Mandela and Abraham Lincoln. What to do with the symbols of a white supremacist past? Well, after the Civil War, Abraham Lincoln did not ban the Confederacy's national anthem "Dixie." Instead, he had it played on the White House lawn, saying, in effect, we're all one nation, this song is all of ours. It's a strategy, I think, Nelson Mandela would understand.
第二幕：纳尔逊·曼德拉和亚伯拉罕·林肯。如何处理白人至上主义过去的象征？好吧，南北战争结束后，亚伯拉罕·林肯并没有禁止邦联的国歌《迪克西》。相反，他让人在白宫草坪上演奏它，实际上是在说，我们是一个国家，这首歌属于我们所有人。我认为，这是一种纳尔逊·曼德拉能够理解的策略。
In fact, that story about Lincoln and Jack Hitt's story about South Carolina reminded me of a story that I had been told by a friend of mine named John Matisonn. John is from South Africa. During apartheid, he was the chief political correspondent at the leading opposition newspaper, The Rand Daily Mail. For a while, he was National Public Radio's correspondent in South Africa, which is how I know him. When Nelson Mandela was released from prison, John was the reporter given the honor of asking Mandela the first question at his very first press conference. Now he's a member of Mandela's government.
事实上，关于林肯的故事和杰克·希特关于南卡罗来纳州的故事，让我想起了我的一个朋友约翰·马蒂森告诉我的一个故事。约翰来自南非。在种族隔离时期，他是领先的反对派报纸《兰德日报》的首席政治记者。有一段时间，他是美国国家公共电台在南非的记者，我就是那样认识他的。当纳尔逊·曼德拉获释时，约翰是那个在曼德拉的第一次新闻发布会上被授予荣誉提问的记者。现在他是曼德拉政府的一员。
And a few years ago, he told me about the Springboks. The Springboks are a rugby team. Under apartheid, rugby was the favorite game of South African whites. Now for blacks, the favorite game, the national game, was soccer. But for whites, it was rugby.
几年前，他告诉我关于跳羚队的事。跳羚队是一支橄榄球队。在种族隔离时期，橄榄球是南非白人最喜欢的运动。现在对于黑人来说，最喜欢的游戏、全国性的游戏是足球。但对白人来说，那是橄榄球。
And the Springboks were the national team, the team that would go to the international competitions, things like that. And it was all white or almost all white, with one or two black players. The Springboks were seen as a symbol of white South Africa and apartheid. When Nelson Mandela's party, the African National Congress, came to power, there was this big debate over whether to get rid of the team's name and its logo. A springbok is like-- it's like a deer. And just like the flag debate in South Carolina, John Matisonn says, the debate got very emotional.
而跳羚队是国家队，是一支会去参加国际比赛的球队，诸如此类。它全是白人或几乎全是白人，只有一两个黑人球员。跳羚队被视为南非白人和种族隔离的象征。当纳尔逊·曼德拉的政党——非洲人国民大会（非国大）——掌权时，关于是否要废除球队的名字和标志引发了激烈的辩论。跳羚是一种像鹿一样的动物。正如南卡罗来纳州的旗帜辩论一样，约翰·马蒂森说，这场辩论变得非常情绪化。
And I would have to say that most people in the ANC camp would have argued strongly that the Springbok cannot be retained. It's too toxic a symbol. It had to be removed and replaced with something else. And there was even discussion about alternatives. And the plan was that a decision was going to be taken after the World Cup.
我必须说，非国大阵营的大多数人都会强烈主张不能保留跳羚标志。它是一个太有毒的象征。它必须被移除并替换为其他东西。甚至还有关于替代方案的讨论。计划是在世界杯之后做出决定。
During apartheid, international sanctions had kept South Africa out of the World Cup. And so at the first World Cup game of the post-apartheid era, a game hosted by South Africa, Nelson Mandela settled this issue of the springbok symbol once and for all.
在种族隔离时期，国际制裁将南非拒之于世界杯之外。因此，在后种族隔离时代的第一场世界杯比赛，也就是南非主办的比赛中，纳尔逊·曼德拉一劳永逸地解决了跳羚标志的问题。
Mandela walked out onto the field wearing a Springbok jersey with the number six, which was the same number as the captain. And he walked out into the middle of the field, and he just wished them well and cheered. And the crowd just roared. And he wore a Springbok cap as well.
曼德拉穿着6号跳羚球衣走上球场，这与队长的号码相同。他走到球场中央，只是祝他们好运并为他们欢呼。人群沸腾了。他还戴了一顶跳羚帽。
And then at the end of the game, South Africa won. And he walked out onto the field, and he hugged the captain of the winning team. And so you had jersey number six hugging jersey number six, the captain of the rugby team and the captain of South Africa.
比赛结束时，南非赢了。他走到场上，拥抱了获胜球队的队长。所以你看到6号球衣拥抱了6号球衣，橄榄球队长和南非队长。
If I remember right, back when it happened, you told me that grown men were crying in the stands.
如果我没记错的话，当年这件事发生时，你告诉我看台上成年男人都在哭。
Oh yeah. It was very emotional. People had tears in their eyes. And I think it had an amazing impact because black South Africans just adored it. They adored him. And white South Africans as well.
哦，是的。非常感人。人们眼里含着泪水。我认为它产生了惊人的影响，因为南非黑人非常崇拜它。他们崇拜他。南非白人也是如此。
They adored the fact that he'd embraced all their symbols, and hadn't rejected them, and made a big fight about it, and turned it into something that could have, potentially at least, at a symbolic level, been ugly. And at the same time, black South Africans said-- it had the effect of people saying, "Well, it's ours. It's not their team anymore. It's our team."
他们崇拜他拥抱了他们所有的象征，而没有排斥它们，也没有为此大吵大闹，并将它变成了一个可能，至少在象征层面可能是丑陋的东西。与此同时，南非黑人说——它产生了一种人们说“好吧，它是我们的。它不再是他们的球队了。它是我们的球队”的效果。
And I think I told you the story that I was at a Christmas party-- our own Christmas party-- and nearly all our staff are black South Africans. And half the black South Africans wore Springbok caps to the Christmas party, which if you're sort of seeped in local political folklore, as I am, it was just an amazing and very moving sight. And frankly, now it's just not an issue. It really isn't.
我想我告诉过你，我在参加圣诞派对——我们自己的圣诞派对——我们几乎所有的员工都是南非黑人。一半的南非黑人戴着跳羚帽参加圣诞派对，如果你像我一样沉浸在当地的政治民间传说中，那只是一个惊人且非常感人的景象。坦率地说，现在这根本不是问题。真的不是。
Nelson Mandela has systematically tried to diffuse the old symbols of apartheid, all of them, of their power. He traveled to formerly all-white neighborhoods. He made the old apartheid national anthem part of the new national anthem. At one point, Nelson Mandela held a lunch, and he invited the wives and the widows of all the prime ministers from during the apartheid era. And he also invited the wives and widows of all the black leaders from that era as well, including Steve Biko's widow.
纳尔逊·曼德拉系统性地试图消除旧种族隔离象征的力量，所有这些象征。他前往以前全是白人的社区。他使旧的种族隔离国歌成为了新国歌的一部分。有一次，纳尔逊·曼德拉举行了一次午宴，他邀请了种族隔离时代所有总理的妻子和遗孀。他还邀请了那个时代所有黑人领袖的妻子和遗孀，包括史蒂夫·比科的遗孀。
And of course, you know that Steve Biko was killed in prison by policemen in support of the old government. And that was in the time under the premiership of John Vorster. And Mrs. Vorster was there. John Vorster died some time ago. But Mrs. Vorster was there.
当然，你知道史蒂夫·比科是被警察关在监狱里杀害的，以支持旧政府。那是在约翰·沃斯特总理任期内。沃斯特夫人也在场。约翰·沃斯特在前段时间去世了。但沃斯特夫人就在那里。
And there was this remarkable scene, which was shown on television and reported in the newspapers, where they're all in the garden, sitting with these garden chairs. And Mrs. Vorster sees Mrs. Biko looking for a place to sit. And she sort of jumps up and offers her her seat. And as you know, John Vorster was really regarded as one of the worst authoritarian leaders. He was minister of police at the same time he was prime minister.
出现了一个非凡的场景，电视上播出了，报纸也报道了，她们都在花园里，坐着这些花园椅。沃斯特夫人看到比科夫人正在找地方坐。她起身给比科夫人让座。正如你所知，约翰·沃斯特确实被视为最糟糕的威权领导人之一。他在担任总理的同时还是警察部长。
And Mandela went up to her, and he brought a chair. And she said, "No, no, no, let me give her my chair." And Mandela looked at her very sternly and wagged his finger at her and said, "Now Mrs. Vorster, you must sit down and do as I say. Otherwise, I'm going to be as authoritarian as your husband was." And everybody laughed quite uncomfortably, not quite sure what to make of it.
曼德拉走到她身边，带来了一把椅子。她说：“不，不，不，让我把我的椅子给她。”曼德拉非常严肃地看着她，摇了摇手指说：“现在，沃斯特夫人，你必须坐下并听我的。否则，我要变得像你丈夫一样专制了。”每个人都尴尬地笑了，不知道该怎么想。
But of course, the next thing, Mrs. Vorster did as she was told by the president. And she sat down. And Mrs. Biko sat down in the chair that Mandela brought for her. And they got into conversation.
但当然，接下来，沃斯特夫人按照总统的话做了。她坐下了。比科夫人坐在曼德拉为她带来的那把椅子上。她们开始交谈。
This actually leads to the thing I was going to ask you next, which was how important do you think these symbolic changes are in changing a nation? How important are they versus, say, building houses and getting the economy working in a different way?
这实际上引出了我接下来要问你的问题，那就是你认为这些象征性的改变在改变一个国家方面有多重要？它们与建设房屋和以不同方式推动经济发展相比，重要性如何？
Well, I must say, I, as a sort of a hard-bitten political journalist all my life, probably didn't take them as seriously as the government did. I looked at housing statistics, and educational changes, and budgets, and all those kind of things. But I have to concede, I was wrong. I failed to appreciate the importance of these symbols. They've been extremely important.
好吧，我必须说，作为一个一生都是顽固的政治记者，我可能没有像政府那样认真地对待它们。我关注住房统计数据、教育变化、预算以及所有这些事情。但我不得不承认，我错了。我没有意识到这些象征的重要性。它们一直非常重要。
I still meet black South African friends who surprise me by telling me about perhaps their less political family members who went, after these symbolic changes, went to parts of white Cape Town and white Johannesburg that they'd never been before. And frankly, they could have gone before because they were not actually legally prohibited for some time before that, but they'd never felt comfortable doing. And so the symbolic change meant, suddenly, people felt symbolically they could go to areas where they might have been legally entitled to for some years, but they wouldn't go there at that time because they still felt uncomfortable. That's, I think, the success.
我仍然遇到黑人南非朋友，他们通过告诉我关于他们那些不那么政治化的家庭成员感到惊讶，这些家庭成员在这些象征性改变之后，去了以前从未去过的白人开普敦和白人约翰内斯堡的部分地区。坦率地说，他们以前本来可以去，因为在那之前有一段时间并没有法律禁止，但他们从未感到舒服。所以象征性的改变意味着，人们突然觉得在象征意义上他们可以去那些虽然多年来在法律上有权进入，但由于依然感到不适而未曾涉足的地区。我认为，这就是成功。
And if you are to ask me, "What has changed for the average black South African since the election?" In terms of housing and so on, the improvements are modest. The vast mass of black South Africans, their material conditions haven't improved radically. And, in many cases, not at all, one has to admit. But what has really changed, and it is a genuine change for people, is psychological liberation, a feeling that this is their country, and that they have opportunities and possibilities in the country, and that the country is theirs. I have to say, I think that has real meaning.
如果你问我，“选举以来普通南非黑人的情况有什么改变？”就住房等方面而言，改善是有限的。绝大多数南非黑人，他们的物质条件并没有得到根本性的改善。人们不得不承认，在许多情况下，根本没有。但真正改变了，并且对人们来说是真正的改变的，是心理上的解放，一种这是他们的国家、在这个国家他们拥有机会和可能、这个国家属于他们的感觉。我不得不说，我认为这具有真正的意义。
John Matisonn in South Africa. Coming up, Good Blacks and Bad Blacks, Good Whites and Bad Whites. That's all in a minute when our program continues.
约翰·马蒂森在南非。接下来，“好黑人和坏黑人，好白人和坏白人。”这一切将在节目继续后的一分钟内呈现。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers, and performers, and reporters to tackle that theme with original documentaries, radio monologues, found tape, anything they can think of. Today's show for the Fourth of July weekend, how we're doing, as a nation, healing the wounds of our nation's original sin of slavery.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们节目的每周都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、表演者和记者，通过原创纪录片、广播独白、寻找磁带等他们能想到的任何方式来处理这个主题。今天的节目是在国庆周末，关于作为一个国家，我们在治愈国家奴隶制原罪的伤口方面做得如何。
We're at Act Three, Good Blacks, Bad Blacks. For a perspective on how far black America and white America have come in integrating into one America, consider this story from New Yorker writer Malcolm Gladwell about his cousins who emigrated to this country from Jamaica 12 years ago, scrimped and saved to make a life here.
现在是第三幕，好黑人，坏黑人。为了从一个视角看看美国黑人和美国白人在融合成一个美国方面走到了多远，请考虑这个由《纽约客》撰稿人马尔科姆·格拉德威尔讲述的关于他的表亲的故事，他们12年前从牙买加移民到这个国家，省吃俭用在这里安家。
My cousin Rosie and her husband Noel live in a two-bedroom bungalow on Argyle Avenue in Uniondale, in a working-class neighborhood on the west end of Long Island. From the outside, their home looks fairly plain. But there's a beautiful park down the street, the public schools are supposed to be good, and Rosie and Noel have built a new garage and renovated the basement.
我的表姐罗西和她的丈夫诺埃尔住在长岛西端一个工人阶级社区，尤尼恩戴尔的阿盖尔大道上的一栋两居室平房里。从外面看，他们的家看起来相当普通。但街尾有一个美丽的公园，公立学校据说也不错，罗西和诺埃尔新建了一个车库并装修了地下室。
Now that Noel has started his own business as an environmental engineer, he has his own office down there. Suite 2B, it says on his stationery. And every morning, he puts on his suit and goes down the stairs to make calls and work on the computer. If Noel's business takes off, Rosie says, she'd like to move to a bigger house in Garden City, which is one town over. She says this even though Garden City is mostly white.
现在诺埃尔已经作为环境工程师创办了自己的公司，他在那里有自己的办公室。文具上写着“2B室”。每天早上，他穿上西装下楼去打电话和在电脑上工作。罗西说，如果诺埃尔的事业有起色，她想搬到加登城的一所更大的房子里，那是一个在隔壁的城镇。尽管加登城大部分是白人，但她还是这么说。
In fact, when she told one of her girlfriends, a black American, about this idea, her friend said that she was crazy, that Garden City was no place for a black person. But that's just the point. Rosie and Noel are from Jamaica. They don't consider themselves black at all.
事实上，当她告诉她的一个女朋友（一位美国黑人）这个想法时，她的朋友说她疯了，加登城根本不是黑人待的地方。但那正是问题的关键。罗西和诺埃尔来自牙买加。他们根本不认为自己是黑人。
This doesn't mean that my cousins haven't sometimes been lumped together with American blacks. Noel had a job once removing asbestos at Kennedy Airport. And his boss called him a nigger and cut his hours. But Noel didn't take it personally. "That boss," he says, "didn't like women or Jews either, or people with college degrees, or even himself, for that matter."
这并不意味着我的表亲有时没有被归入美国黑人中。诺埃尔曾经在肯尼迪机场做过清除石棉的工作。他的老板称他为“黑鬼”并缩减了他的工作时间。但诺埃尔并没有往心里去。“那个老板，”他说，“也不喜欢女人或犹太人，或者有大学学位的人，甚至就这事儿而言，他连自己都不喜欢。”
Another time, Noel found out that a white guy working next to him in the same job and with the same qualifications was making $10,000 a year more than he was. He quit the next day. Noel knows that racism is out there. It's just that he doesn't quite understand or accept the categories on which it depends. The facts of his genealogy, of his nationality, of his status as an immigrant made him, in his own eyes, different.
另一次，诺埃尔发现一个在他旁边做同样工作、资格相同的人每年比他多挣1万美元。他第二天就辞职了。诺埃尔知道种族主义就在那里。只是他不太理解或接受它所依赖的分类。他的家谱、国籍、作为移民的地位等事实，在他自己看来，使他变得与众不同。
This question of who West Indians are and how they define themselves may seem trivial, like racial hairsplitting, but it's not trivial. In the past 20 years, the number of West Indians in America has exploded. There are now half a million in the New York area alone. And despite their recent arrival, they make substantially more money than American blacks. They live in better neighborhoods. Their families are stronger.
关于西印度群岛人是谁以及他们如何定义自己的问题，看起来可能微不足道，就像种族上的吹毛求疵，但它并不微不足道。在过去的20年里，美国的西印度群岛人数量激增。仅在纽约地区现在就有50万。尽管他们是近期才到达，但他们的收入却大大高于美国黑人。他们住在更好的社区。他们的家庭也更稳固。
In the New York area, in fact, West Indians fare about as well as Chinese and Korean immigrants. What does it say about the nature of racism that another group of blacks, who have the same legacy of slavery as their American counterparts and are physically indistinguishable from them as well, can come here and succeed as well as the Chinese and the Koreans do? Is overcoming racism as simple as doing what Noel does, which is to dismiss it, to hold himself above it, to brave it and move on? Why is one group of blacks flourishing when the other is not?
事实上，在纽约地区，西印度群岛人的境况和中国及韩国移民差不多。如果另一群黑人——他们和美国同胞有同样的奴隶制遗产，在生理上和他们也无法区分——能来到这里并取得和中国人及韩国人一样的成功，这说明种族主义的本质是什么？克服种族主义是否就像诺埃尔那样做一样简单：无视它，让自己凌驾于它之上，勇敢面对它并继续前进？为什么一群黑人在繁荣，而另一群却没有？
The implication of West Indian success is that racism doesn't really exist at all, at least, not in the form that we've assumed it does. It implies that when the conservatives in Congress say that the responsibility for ending urban poverty lies not with collective action, but with the poor themselves, that they're right. I think of this sometimes when I go with Rosie and Noel to their church, which is in Hempstead, just about a mile away. It was once a white church, but in the past decade or so, it's been taken over by immigrants from the Caribbean. They've so swelled its membership that the church has bought much of the surrounding property, and it's about to add 100 seats or so to its sanctuary.
西印度群岛人成功的暗示是种族主义根本不存在，至少不是我们假设的那样。它暗示当国会的保守派说结束城市贫困的责任不在于集体行动，而在于穷人自己时，他们是对的。当我随罗西和诺埃尔去他们位于亨普斯特德（距离仅一英里左右）的教堂时，我有时会想到这一点。它曾经是一座白人教堂，但在过去十年左右的时间里，它被来自加勒比地区的移民接管了。他们的会员人数激增，以至于教堂买下了周围大部分房产，并即将为它的圣殿增加大约100个座位。
The pastor, though, is white. And when the band up front is playing and the congregation is in full West Indian form, the pastor sometimes seems out of place, as if he cannot move in time with the music. I always wonder how long the white minister at Rosie and Noel's church will last, whether there won't be some kind of groundswell among the congregation to replace him with one of their own. But Noel tells me the issue has never really come up.
不过，牧师是白人。当前面的乐队在演奏，会众以十足的西印度群岛方式在祈祷时，牧师有时显得格格不入，好像他无法跟上音乐的节奏。我总是想知道罗西和诺埃尔教堂里的那位白人牧师还能撑多久，是否会从会众中产生某种要求用他们自己人取代他的浪潮。但诺埃尔告诉我，这个问题从未真正被提起过。
Noel says, in fact, that he's happier with a white minister for the same reason that he's happy with his neighborhood, where the people across the way are Polish, and another neighbor is Hispanic, and still another is a black American. He doesn't want to be shut off from everybody else, isolated within the narrow confines of his race. He wants to be part of the world. And when he says these things, it's awfully tempting to credit that attitude with what he and Rosie have accomplished. Is this confidence, this optimism, this equanimity all that separates the poorest of American blacks from a house on Argyle Avenue?
事实上，诺埃尔说他更喜欢有一位白人牧师，原因和他喜欢自己的社区一样——那里对面住着波兰人，另一个邻居是西班牙裔，还有一个是美国黑人。他不想被与其他人隔离开来，被限制在自己种族的狭隘范围内。他想成为世界的一部分。当他这么说时，人们非常倾向于把这些成就归功于那种态度。这种自信、这种乐观、这种平静就是把最贫穷的美国黑人与阿盖尔大道上的房子区分开来的唯一东西吗？
This idea of the West Indian as a kind of superior black is not a new one. When the first wave of Caribbean immigrants came to New York and Boston in the early 1900s, other blacks dubbed them "Jew-maicans" in derisive reference to the emphasis they placed on hard work and education. In the 1980s, the economist Thomas Sowell gave the idea serious intellectual imprimatur by arguing that the West Indian advantage was a historical legacy of Caribbean slave culture. According to Sowell, in the American South, slave owners tended to hire managers who were married in order to limit the problems created by sexual relations between overseers and slave women.
这种西印度群岛人是某种“优秀黑人”的想法并不是新的。当第一波加勒比移民在20世纪初来到纽约和波士顿时，其他黑人嘲讽地称他们为“犹太式的牙买加人”，以表示他们对辛勤工作和教育的重视。在20世纪80年代，经济学家托马斯·索维尔通过论证西印度群岛人的优势是加勒比奴隶文化的历史遗产，为这一观点提供了严肃的智力背书。据索维尔说，在美国南部，奴隶主倾向于雇用已婚的管理者，以限制监督者与奴隶女性之间的性关系所产生的问题。
But the West Indies were a hardship post without a large and settled white population. There, the overseers tended to be bachelors. And with white women scarce, there was far more co-mingling of the races. The resulting large group of coloreds soon formed a kind of proto middle class, performing various kinds of skilled and sophisticated tasks that there were not enough whites around to do, as there were in the American South. They were carpenters, masons, plumbers, and small business men many years in advance of their American counterparts, developing skills that required education and initiative.
但西印度群岛是一个缺乏大量稳定白人人口的艰苦岗位。在那里，监督者往往是单身汉。由于白人女性稀少，种族间的交融要多得多。由此产生的大量混血儿很快形成了一种准中产阶级，执行着各种各样的熟练和复杂的任务，而那里不像美国南部那样有足够的白人。他们在很多年里就领先于他们的美国同行，成为了木匠、石匠、水管工和小商人，发展出了需要教育和主动性的技能。
My mother and Rosie's mother came from this colored class. Their parents were schoolteachers in a tiny village buried in the hills of central Jamaica. My grandmother and grandfather's salaries combined put them, at best, on the lower rungs of the middle class. But their expectations went well beyond that. My mother and her sister were pushed to win scholarships to a proper English-style boarding school on the other end of the island. And later, when my mother graduated, it was taken for granted that she would attend university in England.
我的母亲和罗西的母亲就来自这个混血阶层。他们的父母是埋藏在牙买加中部山区一个小村庄里的学校老师。我祖母和祖父的薪水加起来，充其量让他们处于中产阶级的底层。但他们的期望远不止于此。我的母亲和她的姐姐被敦促去赢得牙买加另一端一所正规的英式寄宿学校的奖学金。后来，当我的母亲毕业时，理所当然地认为她将去英国上大学。
My grandparents had ambitions for their children. But it was a special kind of ambition, borne of a certainty that American blacks did not have, that their values were the same as those of society as a whole and that hard work and talent could actually be rewarded. This, I think, is why Noel cannot quite appreciate what it is that weighs black Americans down. He came of age in a country where he belonged to the majority.
我的祖父母对他们的孩子有抱负。但这是一种特殊的抱负，源于一种美国黑人所没有的确定性，即他们的价值观与整个社会的价值观是一样的，努力工作和天赋确实可以得到回报。我想，这就是为什么诺埃尔无法理解是什么让美国黑人感到沉重的原因。他在一个属于多数群体的国家长大。
It is tempting to use the West Indian story as evidence that discrimination doesn't really exist, as proof that the only thing inner-city African-Americans have to do to be welcomed as warmly as West Indians is to make the necessary cultural adjustments. But, in fact, studies of workplaces that hire West Indians show they are not places where traditional racism has been discarded. They're actually places where old-style racism and appreciation of immigrant values are somehow bound up together. Listen to a white manager who was interviewed by the Harvard sociologist Mary Waters.
人们很容易利用西印度群岛人的故事作为歧视并不真正存在的证据，作为证明内城非洲裔美国人若想像西印度群岛人一样受到热烈欢迎，唯一要做的就是进行必要的文化调整的证据。但事实上，对雇用西印度群岛人的工作场所的研究表明，这些地方并不是传统种族主义被抛弃的地方。它们实际上是旧式种族主义和对移民价值观的欣赏以某种方式捆绑在一起的地方。听听哈佛社会学家玛丽·沃特斯采访的一位白人经理的说法。
"Island blacks who come over, they're immigrant. They may not have had such a good life where they are, so they're going to try to strive to better themselves. And I think there's a lot of American blacks out there who feel we owe them. And enough is enough already. You know? This is something that happened to their ancestors, not now. I mean, we've done so much for the black people in America now, it's time that they got off their butts."
“过来这里的岛屿黑人，他们是移民。他们以前的生活可能并不好，所以他们会努力奋斗以改善自己。我认为外面有很多美国黑人觉得我们欠他们的。够了就是够了。你知道吗？这是发生在他们祖先身上的事情，而不是现在。我的意思是，我们现在为美国的黑人做了这么多，他们是时候从懒惰中站起来了。”
Here then are the two competing ideas about racism side by side. The manager issues a blanket condemnation of American blacks even as he holds West Indians up to a cultural ideal. The example of West Indians as good blacks makes the old blanket prejudice against American blacks all the easier to express. The manager can tell black Americans to "get off their butts" without fear of sounding, in his own ears, like a racist because he has simultaneously celebrated island blacks for their work ethic.
这里呈现了关于种族主义的两种竞争观念并列在一起。经理对美国黑人发出了一致的谴责，即使他将西印度群岛人奉为文化理想。将西印度群岛人视为“好黑人”的例子，使得对美国黑人的旧有一致偏见更容易表达出来。经理可以告诉美国黑人“站起来”，而不必担心在自己耳中听起来像个种族主义者，因为他同时称赞了岛屿黑人的职业道德。
The success of West Indians is not proof that discrimination against American blacks does not exist. Rather, it's the means by which discrimination against American blacks is given one last vicious twist, as if to say, "I'm not so shallow as to despise you for the color of your skin because I've found people your color that I like. Now I can despise you for who you are."
西印度群岛人的成功并不能证明对美国黑人的歧视不存在。相反，它是对美国黑人的歧视被赋予最后一次恶毒扭曲的手段，好像在说：“我还不至于肤浅到因为你的肤色而鄙视你，因为我发现了我喜欢的和你肤色相同的人。现在我可以因为你的为人而鄙视你了。”
I grew up in Canada, in a little farming town an hour and a half outside Toronto. My father teaches mathematics at a nearby university. My mother's a therapist. For many years, she was the only black in town. But I can't remember wondering, or worrying, or even thinking about this fact.
我在加拿大长大，在多伦多郊外一个半小时路程的一个小农耕城镇。我父亲在附近的大学教数学。我母亲是一名治疗师。多年来，她是镇上唯一的黑人。但我记不起有对这个事实感到怀疑、担忧，甚至思考过。
Back then, color meant only good things. It meant my cousins in Jamaica. It meant the graduate students from Africa and India my father would bring home from the university. My own color was not something I ever thought about much either because it seemed such a stray fact.
那时，肤色意味着好的东西。它意味着我在牙买加的表亲。它意味着我父亲从大学带回家的非洲和印度研究生。我也从未多想过我自己的肤色，因为它似乎是一个无关紧要的事实。
But things changed when I left for Toronto to attend college. This was during the early 1980s, when West Indians were emigrating to Canada in droves, and Toronto had become second only to New York as the Jamaican expatriates' capital in North America. At school, in the dining hall, I was served by Jamaicans. The infamous Jane Finch projects in northern Toronto were considered the Jamaican projects. The drug trade then taking off was said to be the Jamaican drug trade. In the popular imagination, Jamaicans were, and are, welfare queens, and gun-toting gangsters, and dissolute youths.
但当我离开去多伦多上大学时，情况发生了变化。那是在20世纪80年代初，当时西印度群岛人大批移民到加拿大，多伦多已经成为仅次于纽约的牙买加侨民在北美的首都。在学校的餐厅里，为我服务的是牙买加人。多伦多北部臭名昭著的简·芬奇项目被认为是牙买加人的项目。当时兴起的毒品交易被称为牙买加毒品交易。在大众的想象中，牙买加人是——并将继续是——福利女王、持枪匪徒和放荡的青年。
After I had moved to the United States, I puzzled over this seeming contradiction, how West Indians celebrated in New York for their industry and drive could represent, just 500 miles northwest, crime and dissipation. Didn't Torontonians see what was special and different in West Indian culture? But that was a naive question. The West Indians were the first significant brush with blackness that smug, white Torontonians had ever had. They had no bad blacks to contrast with the newcomers, no African-Americans to serve as a safety valve for their prejudices, no way to perform America's crude racial triage.
在我搬到美国后，我苦苦思索这种看似矛盾的现象：在纽约因其勤劳和进取而受到赞誉的西印度群岛人，在500英里外西北部怎么就代表了犯罪和放荡。难道多伦多人没有看到西印度群岛文化中有什么特别和不同之处吗？但这却是一个幼稚的问题。西印度群岛人是自命不凡的白人多伦多人从未有过的第一次重大黑人接触。他们没有“坏黑人”来与新来者形成对比，没有非裔美国人来作为他们偏见的泄压阀，没有办法进行美国式的粗暴种族分类。
There must be people in Toronto just like Rosie and Noel with the same attitudes and aspirations, who want to live in a neighborhood as nice as Argyle Avenue, who want to build a new garage, and renovate their basement, and set up their own business downstairs. But it's not completely up to them, is it? What has happened to Jamaicans in Toronto is proof that what's happened to Jamaicans here is not the end of racism, or even the beginning of the end of racism, but an accident of history and geography. In America, there is someone else to despise. In Canada, there is not. In the new racism, as in the old, somebody always has to be the nigger.
多伦多一定有像罗西和诺埃尔那样的人，有着同样的态度和抱负，他们想住在像阿盖尔大道那样好的社区，想建一个新的车库，装修地下室，并在楼下建立自己的生意。但这不完全取决于他们，不是吗？发生在多伦多的牙买加人的事情证明，发生在我们这里的牙买加人的事情并不是种族主义的终结，甚至不是种族主义终结的开始，而是一个历史和地理的偶然。在美国，有别人可以鄙视。在加拿大，却没有。在新的种族主义中，就像在旧的种族主义中一样，总得有人来当那个黑鬼。
Malcolm Gladwell's story first appeared in the New Yorker magazine.
马尔科姆·格拉德威尔的故事首次出现在《纽约客》杂志上。
Act Four, Good Whites, Bad Whites. This next assessment of our state of national racial healing, from radio producer Cecilia Vaisman and Christina Egloff with Jay Allison, about a woman named Carolyn Wren Shannon and her neighbors.
第四幕：好白人，坏白人。接下来这份关于我们国家种族治愈状况的评估，来自电台制作人塞西莉亚·韦斯曼和克里斯蒂娜·埃格洛夫，以及杰·艾利森，讲述了一位名叫卡罗琳·雷恩·香农及其邻居的故事。
My mother was telling us that one time, when we were younger, my father was very prejudiced. And I come home from school with this friend. And he was on the recliner with a newspaper. And I said, "Mum, can my friend stay over for supper?" And my father dropped the paper to look to see who it was, and it was a little black girl. She said, my father almost swallowed his false teeth.
我母亲告诉我们，有一次我们年轻的时候，我父亲非常有偏见。我带这个朋友从学校回来。他正坐在躺椅上看报纸。我说：“妈妈，我的朋友能留下来吃晚饭吗？”我父亲放下报纸去看是谁，结果是个黑人小女孩。她说，我父亲差点把假牙咽下去。
And she was like, "Honey, I don't really think that's a good idea." She said, I come in, and my father was horrified. Because I really didn't see things-- I don't know. I was colorblind really until that incident. And then we kind of got the rules that that wasn't accepted.
她是那种，“亲爱的，我不认为这是个好主意。”她说，我走进来时，我父亲感到震惊。因为我真的没看到事情——我不知道。在那件事之前，我真的是色盲。然后我们就像是得到了那种不被接受的规则。
Who you calling?
你在叫谁？
Ready?
准备好了吗？
[CHEERING] Go. F-I-G-H-T, fight, fight. F-I-G-H-T, fight, fight.
[欢呼声] 走。F-I-G-H-T，战斗，战斗。F-I-G-H-T，战斗，战斗。
My mother and father are both from Charlestown. All of my great-grandparents are from Ireland. All four of them. And that's how the majority of this community works.
我的母亲和父亲都来自查尔斯顿。我所有的曾祖父母都来自爱尔兰。四个都是。这就是这个社区大多数人的情况。
Most of them, when they come over on the boat, they all were together and settled together. And that's how this community has stayed the same. You'll find that a lot of the people in this community are related because I think there's some security having family around. And people are proud that their Irish, and they're proud that they're Catholic.
他们中大多数人坐船过来时，他们都待在一起并定居在一起。这就是这个社区保持不变的方式。你会发现这个社区里的很多人都是亲戚，因为我觉得有家人在身边有一种安全感。人们为自己是爱尔兰人而自豪，为自己是天主教徒而自豪。
And I think people-- they stick to their own. When we were in grammar school, there was one teen who was Protestant. And we goofed on him because he didn't believe in the same thing as us. Course, no one understood what a Protestant was, just that he was different.
而且我觉得人们——他们坚守自己人。当我们上小学时，有一个青少年是新教徒。我们捉弄他，因为他不相信和我们一样的东西。当然，没有人明白什么是新教徒，只知道他与众不同。
Are you ready, girls? [MAKES A HUMMING SOUND, SETTING THE PITCH] Go ahead. Go. Follow her lead.
准备好了吗，女孩们？[发出嗡嗡声，设定音调] 开始吧。走。跟着她的节奏。
[SINGING] We are the girls from Charlestown you hear so much about. Most everybody looks at us whenever we go out. We're noted for our reputation and the things we do. But what the hell do we care? The boys are naughty too.
[歌唱] 我们就是你们常听说的查尔斯顿女孩。每当我们出门，大家都看着我们。我们以我们的名声和我们所做的事情而闻名。但我们才不在乎呢？男孩子们也很淘气。
Wasn't that fun?
好玩吗？
Drink with the straws. You know the little--
用吸管喝。你知道那个小——
We are here at my Aunt Mary Ellen's house on Elm Street in Charlestown. I'm here with my Aunt Linda, my cousin Patty, my cousin Donna, my sister-in-law Mimi, my cousin Mary Ann, my Aunt Barbara, my cousin Sheila, and my Aunt Mary Ellen. My grandmother, who is the matriarch of this wonderful family. Mary Wren, wonderful woman, she had seven children. And she had 32 grandchildren and 43 great-grandchildren. I'd say about 70% are still local.
我们现在是在我玛丽·艾伦阿姨位于查尔斯顿榆树街的家里。我和我的琳达阿姨、帕蒂表姐、唐娜表姐、嫂子咪咪、玛丽·安表姐、芭芭拉阿姨、希拉表姐和玛丽·艾伦阿姨在一起。我的祖母，她是我们这个大家庭的女族长。玛丽·雷恩，了不起的女人，她有七个孩子。她有32个孙子孙女和43个曾孙。我想大约70%的人现在还在本地。
Most people don't understand it if they're from the town. There's always that Charlestown-- they want to be, they wish they were, they don't understand what it's like.
如果是外地人，大多数人不理解。总是那样查尔斯顿——他们想成为，他们希望他们是，他们不了解那是什么感觉。
There's strength in numbers. And that's what happens here. Everybody knows everybody. So it's a kind of strength that you don't find in other areas. To have 17,000 people and the majority of them have major relatives around, it makes a big difference in this community.
人多力量大。这就是这里发生的事情。每个人都认识每个人。所以这是一种你在其他地区找不到的力量。拥有17000人，且大多数人都有主要的亲戚在身边，这对这个社区来说产生了巨大的不同。
Charlestown is home.
查尔斯顿是家。
Yeah.
是的。
Once busing occurred, that wonderful year of '76, 1976, when the federal government mandated busing, court-ordered busing, my junior year was totally insane. Everything changed. There were new faces. People were never exposed to minorities. And all of a sudden, you're thrown in a classroom.
一旦校车接送发生，1976年那个美妙的年份，联邦政府强制校车接送，法院下令校车接送，我的高三那年完全疯了。一切都变了。有了新面孔。人们从来没有接触过少数族裔。突然之间，你被扔进了一间教室。
And there's turmoil on the streets, and there's turmoil in your house, and there's turmoil on the news. And the city's erupted with racial violence. And everyone's following everyone. Whatever the crowd does. If they throw rocks, you throw rocks. If they beat up a black person, then you stand and watch.
街上有骚乱，家里有骚乱，新闻里也有骚乱。整个城市爆发了种族暴力。每个人都在跟随每个人。群众做什么，就做什么。如果他们扔石头，你就扔石头。如果他们殴打黑人，你就站在那儿看。
Whereas, as a Catholic, you realize that you don't treat someone like that. But everyone forgot everything. It was like this total mayhem.
然而，作为一个天主教徒，你意识到你不应该那样对待别人。但每个人都忘了这一切。那就像是一场彻头彻尾的混乱。
School wasn't the same. There were metal detectors put in the classroom, in the entrance of the schools. There were policemen everywhere. At night, they would burn cars. It was total crazy.
学校不再一样了。教室里、学校入口处都装了金属探测器。到处都是警察。晚上，他们会烧车。那真是完全疯了。
There was a major rally on Boston, City Hall Plaza. And a black man was attacked with an American flag because he was black and walked in front of their rally, which was all white. They speared him with the American flag. It was a horrible, horrible scene.
波士顿市政厅广场上举行了一场大型集会。一个黑人被美国国旗袭击，因为他是黑人，而且走在了集会前面，而集会上全是白人。他们用美国国旗刺他。那是一个可怕、可怕的场景。
It was all over the news across the world. Charlestown, Southie, they're racist. Boston is a place full of hate. And it was. It was.
全世界的新闻都报道了。查尔斯顿，南波士顿，他们是种族主义者。波士顿是一个充满仇恨的地方。确实是。确实是。
Just start it.
开始吧。
[CHEERING] [UNINTELLIGIBLE] is the team that we're gonna defeat, so come on, everybody, do the Townie beat.
[欢呼声] [听不清] 是我们要打败的球队，所以来吧，每个人，跳起小镇舞步。
Once, guys, come on. Let's go.
伙计们，一次，来吧。我们走。
[CHEERING] One, two, three, four, clap, one, two, clap, one, two, three, four, five, six, clap, one, two, clap, one, two, clap, clap.
[欢呼声] 一、二、三、四，拍手，一、二，拍手，一、二、三、四、五、六，拍手，一、二，拍手，一、二，拍手，拍手。
When I was in junior high, the biggest thing was to get up to the high school because that was where your mother went and your father went. And those teachers were still there. And you could still talk to your mother about the bathroom story. But that doesn't occur anymore because there is no Charlestown High like it used to be. And now the school itself is predominately black.
当我上初中时，最大的事情就是升上高中，因为那是你母亲和你父亲去过的地方。那些老师还在那儿。你仍然可以和你母亲谈论洗手间的故事。但这不再发生了，因为查尔斯顿高中不再是原来的样子了。现在学校本身主要是黑人了。
My kids will probably go to parochial schools. They won't do Charlestown High cheers. They may do St. Clement's cheers.
我的孩子们可能去教区学校。他们不会跳查尔斯顿高中的啦啦队舞。他们可能会跳圣克莱门特的啦啦队舞。
But when my aunts get together, they all sing Charlestown High songs. And it's like a little pep rally when we're all at a family gathering. But that won't happen for my kids. And I think that's kind of sad.
但当我的阿姨们聚在一起时，她们都会唱查尔斯顿高中的歌。当我们全家聚会时，就像一场小型的动员大会。但这不会发生在我的孩子们身上。我觉得这有点悲哀。
Put your hands on your hips, and we'll do it regular. OK, put 'em up. Close your feet. Say, ready.
把手放在臀部，我们跳正规的。好的，举起来。闭上脚。说，准备。
[CHEERING] Go. Townie team means victory any way you spell it.
[欢呼声] 走。小镇球队意味着胜利，无论你怎么拼写它。
Hey, very good, girls.
嘿，非常好，女孩们。
What does Townie team mean?
小镇球队意味着什么？
Townie Teenie. You gonna go to cheerleading today? Huh? We're gonna go down to cheerleading?
小镇青少年。你今天去参加啦啦队训练吗？哈？我们去参加啦啦队训练好吗？
What happened on the Oprah show was she had on a white man who was married to a white woman. He disowned his children for being associated with black men. And then he, in fact, disowned his grandchildren because they were black in them. And I was saying, "That's a disgrace. That's your blood. You don't disown anyone." And Danny said--
奥普拉节目上发生的事情是，她请来了一个娶了白人妻子的白人男子。他因为他的孩子们与黑人交往而与他们断绝关系。然后，事实上，他与他的孙辈断绝了关系，因为他们身体里有黑人血统。我说：“那是一个耻辱。那是你的血脉。你不应该与任何人断绝关系。”然后丹尼说——
I don't know. What did I say?
我不知道。我说了什么？
You said that you thought he was right.
你说你认为他是对的。
I said I don't know what I would do. But I understood his feelings. So you wouldn't mind your daughters marrying a black guy?
我说我不知道我会怎么做。但我理解他的感受。所以你不介意你的女儿嫁给黑人吗？
I didn't say that, which we have discussed at great length. That is definitely a fear of mine, that I would like to think I'm open minded about race, more so than I've ever been. But if it came down to my daughters choosing another race, I don't think I'd be happy with that.
我没那么说，我们对此讨论了很久。那绝对是我的恐惧，我想认为我在种族问题上是开明的，比我以往任何时候都开明。但如果最终我的女儿选择了另一种族，我想我不会对此感到高兴。
I wouldn't say I'm racist, but I definitely have bitter feelings towards blacks. I was raised that way too. My father's an Archie Bunker. I think it rubs off on you.
我不会说我是种族主义者，但我对黑人绝对有苦涩的感觉。我从小也是那样长大的。我父亲是个阿奇·邦克。我认为这会影响到你。
I would never say anything to my girls. But they'll learn. They'll learn what's theirs, what's your own, and things like that just growing up around the same type of people. They'll look at anyone that's not like them differently. I don't have to tell them that.
我永远不会对我的女孩们说什么。但她们会学会的。她们会学会什么是她们的，什么是你自己的，以及类似的事情，就像在同一类人身边长大一样。她们会以不同的眼光看待任何不像她们的人。我不必告诉她们。
It sounds ignorant, but I had no pro-- I like the way I grew up. Carolyn's of the same mold. And I don't have a problem with that. I'm not gonna push it on 'em at all.
这听起来很无知，但我没有……我喜欢我成长的方式。卡罗琳也是同样的模子。我对此没有问题。我一点也不会强迫她们。
But I hope someday they marry an Irish-Catholic boy. I don't think there's anything wrong with that. Other people say, that's being racial. I think it's natural to like your own kind of people.
但我希望有一天她们能嫁给一个爱尔兰裔天主教男孩。我不认为这有什么不对。其他人会说，那是种族主义。我认为喜欢和你自己人在一起是很自然的。
You sing too, Bridget. Help her out.
你也唱，布丽奇特。帮帮她。
[SINGING] I love you. You love me. We're a happy family. With a great big hug and a kiss from me to you. Won't you say you love me too?
[歌唱] 我爱你。你爱我。我们是幸福的一家。给我一个大大的拥抱和吻，从我到你。你愿意说你也爱我吗？
I think it's a real breed of person. You must have to grow up somewhere where you walk down the street, and there's a black kid, a Chinese kid, a white kid, and a Puerto Rican kid playing together. I just can't even imagine that. That's some kind of a made-up fairy tale, I think, where everyone gets along together. I can't imagine it.
我认为那是一个真正的人种。你一定得在某个地方长大，在那里你走在街上，有黑人小孩、中国小孩、白人小孩和波多黎各小孩一起玩。我简直无法想象。我认为那是一种虚构的童话故事，在那里每个人都能和睦相处。我无法想象。
Life teaches you sometimes very painfully. And I think that's your best teacher anyway. No one can tell you not to be racist, and they can't tell you to like your black neighbor. You have to learn. So I think it's a person's choice. So you can choose to be ignorant, or you can choose to be fair.
生活有时会非常痛苦地教导你。而且我认为那反正是你最好的老师。没人能告诉你不要成为种族主义者，他们也不能告诉你去喜欢你的黑人邻居。你必须去学习。所以我认为这是个人的选择。所以你可以选择无知，或者你可以选择公正。
I was captain of the cheerleaders. And I remember Miss Kessner, which was the cheerleading coach, was also the phys ed director. And she said, she hadn't chose the captains yet. And this was something that I wanted my whole life. This was my big goal in life to be cheerleading captain.
我是啦啦队长。我记得凯斯纳小姐，她是啦啦队教练，也是体育总监。她说她还没选队长。这是我一生中一直想要的东西。这是我人生中最大的目标，成为啦啦队队长。
And she said to me one day, "If a black girl tries out for cheerleading, will you accept her?" And I thought to myself, "I'm gonna be a jerk if I don't go along with the crowd." It was a very difficult decision for me. And I knew this could jeopardize whether I'd become captain or not. And I said, "I wouldn't accept her." She put her head down, and she walked away.
有一天她对我说：“如果有黑人女孩来参加选拔，你会接受她吗？”我心想，“如果我不跟群众保持一致，我会是个混蛋。”那对我来说是一个非常困难的决定。我知道这可能会危及我是否能成为队长。我说：“我不会接受她。”她低下头，走开了。
So the day of cheerleading tryouts, she come into the room of all the girls, and she said, "Traditionally, Charlestown High has had two cheerleading captains. This year, they'll only be one." And I put my head down, and I started to cry because I knew I blew it. It was my first experience with race and making the wrong decision.
到了啦啦队选拔的那天，她走进所有女孩的房间说：“传统上，查尔斯顿高中一直有两个啦啦队队长。今年，只有一个。”我低下头，开始哭，因为我知道我搞砸了。那是我第一次经历种族问题并做出了错误的决定。
So we're all in the room, and she says, "The cheerleading captain for this year is Carolyn Wren." I started bawling my eyes out. And I was like, "Oh, my god." And I looked up at her. And she knew that I knew that I had made a wrong choice. I knew I made the wrong choice, but I made it from my heart because I was raised in a house where race wasn't accepted.
所以我们都在房间里，她说：“今年的啦啦队队长是卡罗琳·雷恩。”我开始大哭。我心想，“哦，天哪。”我抬头看着她。她知道我知道我做出了错误的选择。我知道我做出了错误的选择，但我发自内心地做出了那个选择，因为我在一个不接受种族的家庭里长大。
That's crazy. That's embarrassing. I think they're embarrassing, the Charlestown High cheerleaders.
太疯狂了。太尴尬了。我认为她们很尴尬，查尔斯顿高中的啦啦队队员。
What's wrong with them?
她们怎么了？
Because they don't cheer like your regular cheerleaders anyway. They cheer like jigaboos or something. I don't know. Carol, that is not cheering. It's boge. They're like clapping, and singing, and getting down with their cheers. It's not even--
因为她们跳得不像正规的啦啦队队员。她们跳得像……我不知道。卡罗琳，那不是拉拉队加油。那很傻。她们拍手、唱歌，沉浸在加油声中。那甚至不是——
It's jive cheerleading.
那是爵士风格的啦啦队加油。
It's jive cheering. Yeah.
是爵士啦啦队加油。是的。
It's not your good old cheerleader cheering.
那不是你好的老式啦啦队加油。
It's not what they teach you at cheerleading camp. The all-American cheerleader. It's not that style. It's more ethnic. It's more cultural. It's very different than what we're used to.
那不是他们在啦啦队夏令营教你的。全美啦啦队队员。那不是那种风格。它更具民族性。它更具文化性。它与我们习惯的不同。
Definitely.
绝对是。
See, my sisters wouldn't cheer for Charlestown High because of it. I can't even think of a cheer that we could compare it to other than "How funky is your chicken."
看，我的姐妹们不会为查尔斯顿高中加油，因为这个。我甚至想不出一个可以与之相比的加油词，除了“你的鸡肉有多时髦”。
No, they do that "We don't need no music to cheer." And they stamp their feet. And they do like this little dance.
不，她们会跳“我们不需要音乐来加油”。然后她们跺脚。她们跳那种小舞。
And they do like [CLAPS AND STAMPS]. Oh, you want to just slap them and say, "Stop, you look so foolish."
她们做那种[拍手和跺脚]。哦，你只想扇她们一巴掌说：“停下，你们看起来太傻了。”
But that's all they know. That's what they're taught. And that's what they're excited to do.
但这正是她们所知道的。这就是她们被教的。这就是她们兴奋地做的事情。
Nobody's excited to have 'em. Everybody just wished they'd go away.
没人高兴有她们。每个人只是希望她们离开。
I remember sitting beside a girl in school. And she had an Afro. And we had common pins in health. Not health. Sewing. It was home ec.
我记得在学校坐在一个女孩旁边。她留着爆炸头。我们在健康课上有普通别针。不是健康。缝纫。那是家政课。
And we used to put paper at the end of the common pin and toss the common pin. And the paper would allow it to weigh it down, so you could send it. And we would put them into her hair. And this was hitting her head.
我们过去常在普通别针末端放纸，然后扔出去。纸会让它沉下来，这样你就能发送它。我们会把它扔进她的头发里。它撞到了她的头。
We tortured that girl because she was different and because she had an Afro, and none of us did. Because she was black. And I was a part of that. I was as racist as the next one. It's not something I'm proud of.
我们折磨那个女孩，因为她与众不同，因为她有爆炸头，而我们都没有。因为她是黑人。我也是其中的一部分。我和其他人一样是种族主义者。这不是我引以为傲的事。
And I think working with teenagers, it's a constant effort to remind them that you don't judge someone by the color of their skin.
而且我认为与青少年一起工作，提醒他们不要以肤色来判断一个人是一个不断的努力。
OK, tonight's conference is gonna be on racism. We realize it's a very sensitive issue. We're not here to try to change anybody's mind. All we want to do is raise your consciousness about it. Want to talk about it. Want to have a lot of fun with it. Couple of rules. Watch your mouth. No swearing. A little respect. You can, of course, speak your own opinions, but with a little taste. Understand? OK, we're gonna start.
好的，今晚的会议将关于种族主义。我们意识到这是一个非常敏感的问题。我们在这里不是为了尝试改变任何人的想法。我们只想提高你们的意识。想谈论它。想从中获得很多乐趣。几条规则。管好你的嘴。不准骂人。保持一点尊重。当然，你们可以发表自己的意见，但要有点品位。明白吗？好的，我们要开始了。
If you asked me when I was 10, would I be working for the city with other black people, I would've told you, you were crazy, that I'm above them, that I don't work with niggers. That's what I woulda told you when I was 10.
如果我在10岁时问你，我会和黑人一起为城市工作吗？我会告诉你，你疯了，我凌驾于他们之上，我不会和黑鬼一起工作。如果我10岁时，那就是我会告诉你的。
Yeah, when I first took this job, I actually had trouble working with people across the city because I was really racist. But I was in the high school when there was busing. So there was a lot of racial riots. There was total mayhem every day. I hated them. It was just those things and their Afros.
是的，当我第一次接受这份工作时，我真的很难与整个城市的人一起工作，因为我真的很种族主义。但我在高中时经历了校车接送。所以有很多种族骚乱。每天都有完全的混乱。我恨他们。那只是那些东西和他们的爆炸头。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I hated them. I didn't want to look at them. I didn't want to talk to them. I was the class vice president and almost lost the post because I wouldn't accept black students in Charlestown High.
我恨他们。我不想看他们。我不想和他们说话。我是班级副主席，差点失去了职位，因为我不接受查尔斯顿高中的黑人学生。
I've taken incredible strides as far as accepting. I've matured. I'm educated. It's very different than when I was 17, and filled with a lot of hate, and was surrounded by a lot of people who hated because of the color of their skin.
在接受方面，我取得了令人难以置信的进步。我成熟了。我受过教育。这与我17岁时、充满仇恨、被周围许多因为肤色而仇恨的人包围时非常不同。
OK, this warm-up-- guys, you need to listen-- this warm-up is called motion circle. So what I want you to do is walk-- spread out a little more-- and I want you to walk. Come this way. Just walk in a circle. OK, now I'm going to tell you do something. I want you to all of a sudden do it, OK? Walk like you're stuck in quicksand.
好的，这个热身——伙计们，你们需要听——这个热身叫动作圆圈。所以我想要你们做的是走——散开一点——我想要你们走。往这边走。只需围成一个圆圈走。好的，现在我要告诉你们做某事。我想要你们突然做，好吗？走得像陷入流沙一样。
Stuck in what?
陷进什么？
Stuck in quicksand. Walk like you're Irish.
陷进流沙。像爱尔兰人那样走。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
OK. Keep walking. Walk as if you're carrying something heavy. OK, walk like you're black.
好的。继续走。走得好像你带着沉重的东西。好的，走得像个黑人。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
My father, who used to be incredibly racist and has grown out of that-- I can't even believe it. He's just not the same person. And he accepts people for what they are, which was very important for all of us to see. Because you lead by example. And if you can't lead by example-- it's such an important part of, I think, each family.
我父亲，他过去非常种族主义，现在已经改过来了——我简直不敢相信。他已经不是同一个人了。他按人的本色接受他们，这对于我们所有人来说都很重要。因为你是以身作则。如果你不能以身作则——我认为这是每个家庭中非常重要的一部分。
And I would say, on a whole, that the majority of racism is learned in the home. It's what you're brought up with. It's what you hear. It's what you're told. And it's how you're raised.
我想说，总的来说，大部分种族主义是在家里学到的。这是你从小受到的教育。这是你听到的。这是你被告知的。这就是你的成长方式。
And if you go out and you think that battering someone because they're black, then I would bet my paycheck that, in your home, racism is a serious issue and also a serious problem. And it was for me. And it's taken me a long, long time to overcome it. Although I still have fears. Although I'm open minded and educated, I still have some of those fears.
如果你出去并且认为殴打某人是因为他们是黑人，那么我敢拿我的工资打赌，在你的家里，种族主义是一个严重的问题，也是一个严重的问题。对我来说也是如此。我花了很长、很长的时间才克服它。虽然我仍然有恐惧。虽然我开明且受过教育，但我仍然有一些那种恐惧。
That story was first produced in a slightly longer form for WGBH in Jay Allison's Life Stories series. Engineering by Jane Pipik. Cecilia Vaisman did the original interviews.
那个故事最早以稍长的形式为WGBH的杰·艾利森《人生故事》系列制作。简·皮皮克负责工程。塞西莉亚·韦斯曼进行了原始采访。
Well, our program was produced today by Elise Spiegel and myself with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder. Musical help from Sarah Vowell. Contributing editors Sarah Vowell, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Paul Tough. To buy a cassette of this program, call us at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. That's 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] .
好吧，我们今天的节目由爱丽丝·斯皮格尔和我自己制作，南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德参与。莎拉·沃威尔提供音乐帮助。特约编辑莎拉·沃威尔、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和保罗·托夫。要购买此节目的磁带，请致电芝加哥的WBEZ，电话是312-832-3380。号码是312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址是 [email protected]。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金来源鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who makes most of his management decisions this way.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他大多数管理决策都以这种方式做出。
I went, and I prayed.
我去祈祷了，我决定——
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台，PRI。